a
[Música]
la situación de refugiados asilados
inmigrantes ilegales ha puesto al
descubierto la crisis en el sistema
migratorio del reino unido con largas
listas de espera los grupos más
vulnerables son precisamente la de los
migrantes ilegales ya que no tienen
acceso a vivienda ni tampoco trabajos no
están protegidos por el sistema de
bienestar social y muchos de ellos viven
apenas con 5.6 libras al día en promedio
organizaciones no gubernamentales como
réferi action señalan que las
solicitudes de asilados tardan más de
seis meses algunas años y muchos de
estos asilados se encuentran en centros
de detención con los mínimos recursos
para sobrevivir además de la pandemia el
break sheet que concluirá el próximo 31
de diciembre y pondrá fin al libre
movimiento de personas va a provocar un
rezago aún mayor en el número de
solicitudes de las personas que quieren
quedarse en el reino unido- o venir en
busca de mejores oportunidades de vida
[Música]
debido a la pandemia y al cierre de
fronteras el crecimiento poblacional de
australia este año será de tan sólo 0 2%
la tasa más baja en más de 100 años
teniendo en cuenta que desde el 20 de
marzo únicamente pueden ingresar al país
ciudadanos y residentes permanentes el
gobierno federal anunció que va a
priorizar las solicitudes de visas
temporales de residencia permanente y de
ciudadanía de personas que están al
interior del país esto por supuesto va a
beneficiar a quienes están aquí porque
podrán renovar sus visas temporales o
adquirir su residencia permanente con
una mayor posibilidad de éxito pero va a
perjudicar a cerca de 3500 estudiantes
internacionales que cuentan con visa
temporal australiana pero que debido al
virus se quedaron por fuera del país el
gobierno federal estima que sólo a
finales del próximo año 2021 abrirá sus
fronteras a turistas y también a
estudiantes extranjeros y esto en gran
parte depende de la vacuna del próximo
año entonces australia empezará a
regular su migración neta y para 2022 el
país espera pasar de 25 a 26 millones de
habitantes
[Música]
canadá ha limitado el paso por sus
fronteras desde marzo bloqueando lo que
el gobierno llama viajes no esenciales
pero la pandemia también ha afectado a
los migrantes que buscan quedarse el
país está aceptado solicitudes de visas
de estudio trabajo y residencia
permanente pero los abogados de
inmigración advierten que hay demoras en
el procesamiento y que la aprobación no
es suficiente para cruzar la frontera en
el segundo trimestre del 2020 satish
tips canadá contó más de 30.000 nuevos
residentes permanentes muchos ya en el
país en contraste con más de 290 mil del
año anterior en este periodo comparado
con el 2019 que anda en nicho el 50 por
ciento de los permisos de trabajo y
menos del 10 por ciento de los de
estudio sin embargo el gobierno federal
insiste en que la inmigración será clave
para la recuperación post pandemia tras
un verano de protestas abrió la
posibilidad a trabajadores de salud en
la primera línea del cobi y que buscan
asilo para que puedan aplicar ya a su
residencia
[Música]